[موسيقى]
ونحيكم مشاهدينا من جديد كشف تقرير جديد
للامم المتحده ان كل ساعه من العام السابق
2021 شهدا في متوسط قتل خمس نساء او فتيات
على ايدي شركاء حياتهن او فرد من اسرهن
وافد التقرير ان نحو 56 بالمئه من جميع
جرائم القتل بحق النساء والفتيات اي
45,000 من 81000 ارتكبها شركاء او حياتهن
او افراد
تقرير حسب وكاله الانباء الالمانيه ان
العدد المرتفعه بصوره مقلقه من جرائم قتل
النساء والفتيات لم يشهد تغيرا خلال
الاعوام القليله الماضيه بالاضافه الى ذلك
ربما يكون هناك عدد كبير من الحالات التي
لم يتم الابلاغ عنها ودعت وكالات الامم
المتحده الى توفير حمايه افضل للنساء
والفتيات والى جهود منسقه تحرك من قبل
المجتمع تكفل حقوق النساء والفتيات في
الشعور بالامن في المنزل وفي الشوارع وفي
كل مكان
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من القاهره
الدكتوره ام رضوان استاذه علم الاجتماع
والعلاقات الاسريه اهلا بك من تونس رضيع
جربي رئيسه الاتحاد الوطني للمراه
التونسيه اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام واسمحوا
لي ان ابدا من تونس معك سيده راضيه سيده
راضيه في الواقعه لما طلعنا على هذه
الارقام خمس فتيات او نساء في غضون ساعه
في سنه 2021 بحسب الامم المتحده همم الرقم
والنسبه فظيعه همم فما الاسباب بحسب
وحذرتك رئيسه الاتحاد الوطني للمراه
التونسيه والاكيد بانك مطلعه على دخل
التونسي وحتى لك فكره على ما يحدث في
العالم ليس فقط لا نتحدث على دول العربيه
فهمم ما ابرز الاسباب التي تدفع بشريك او
برفيق الى قتل فتاه او زوجه
مرحبا بك وبكلمك وفي زميله من القاهره
شكرا على طرح هذا الموضوع في هذه الايام
التي نحتفل فيها بالايام الامميه لمنااهده
كل اشكال العنف المسلط عن النساء الرقم
مفزع فعلا ولكنه غير مفاجئ لانه في
الحقيقه مساله قتل النساء ظاهره عرفناها
منذ سنوات حتى في تونس ارتفع عدد ضحايا
بشكل لافتت واصبحنا نتحدث عن قتل النساء
نتيجه العنف داخل الاسره او العنف الزوج
لماذا لاسباب عديده لعل اهمها ان القانون
لم ينجح في الحد من العنف المسلط عن
النساء الارقام المفزعه في العنف بشكل عام
تبين وان ليس هنالك تراجع في ممارسته تجاه
النساء وان القوانين لم تكن وحدها كافيه
للحد من
ما يحدث في العالم همم وفي دولنا ايضا
العربيه وفي تونس وانا العقليه الذكوريه
ما زالت سائده ما زال الرجل يعتقد ان قوته
البدنيه اتسمح له بان يكون له سلطه
والسلطان على المراه ما زال الوضع
الاقتصادي والاجتماعي للنساء
يجعلهم ضحايا للعنف وايضا غياب الحوارات
غياب النقاش غياب ثقافه
التحاور داخل البيت
غياب الديمقراطيه انشانا في بلداننا ومنها
داخل الاسره لنتحدث نتحاول في مسائل اسريه
وعائليه وان ما هنالك واحد يرتفع ويعلو
واحيانا هذا الصوت عندما يتعارض مع صوت
اخر يريد ان يناقشه او
يعني يتحاور معه يجدوا همم قوه معناها
كبيره قوه عنف تخمد صوته الى الابد وهو ما
يحدث ايضا في بلدان ايضا تراجع الاحكام
ونعود القوانين ولكن الاستاذه راضيه فقط
لنبقى في اطار المجتمع وحتى همم نشارك
معنا كذلك الدكتور امر رضوان استاذه علم
الاجتماع والعلاقات الاسريه دكتوره امل
لقائنا ان يقول بان المجتمعات تتطور همم
يعني اليوم هناك اكثر نسبه تعليم اكثر
نسبه اختلاط اكثر نسبه همم مدارس جامعات
همم الفتيات اليوم يشاركنا
ويتميزنا في الدراسه وحتى في الشغل ولكن
همم النظره الفكر بحسب على الاقل الكلام
للاستاذ راضيه لم يتغير ما التفسير
حاليا بنعيش تقدم تكنولوجي معاه يصاحبه
تاخر انساني وتاخر اخلاقي يمكن لازاله
العقليه ذكوريه مسيطره بالفعل على معظم
الدول العربيه منطقه الشرق الاوسط كلها
وده سبب رئيسي جدا اللي هي النظره الدونيه
او ان المراه مواطن درجه ثانيه ده بيكون
فعلا اا سبب رئيسي فكره التمييز ضد المراه
اللي زال في عقليه ناس كثيره جدا حتى في
الموروثات همم الشعبيه او بعض الامثال زي
اكثر للبنت طلعت لها 24 بالتاكيد ال- ال-
المفاهيم دي همم الراسخه في العقول
وبتتورثها جيل وفكره ان هو عادي بيادب
زوجته بيربيها لما يعملها بعنف فهو ده
التطور اللي بيحصل ده ظاهره العنف اللي هي
بتوصل لحد القتل فانا قدام بالفعل همم
ثقافه مجتمع محتاجه انها تتغير كثير جنبا
الى جنب مع تشريعات راضعه للعنف الاسريين
يمكن العنف الاسري كثير منه بيبقى في
البدايات مسكوت عنه يعني ما بتبقى ال ال
المراه تخجل انها تشتكي زوجها او تشتكي
والدها اذا كان بيتعامل مع بعنف او احد او
اي احد من افراد الاسره لا زالت النظره
المجتمعيه انها هي لو اشتكت تبقى هي
المخطئه على عكس رغم انه هو المعتدي او هو
اللي بيتعامل معها بقسوه بدون رحمه ولكن
الدكتوره امل صحيح ولكن هذا هذا النوع من
التعامل هل يقتصر على المجتمع معين هل
يقتصر على فئه معينه هل يقتصر على عمر
معين يعني هل هناك احصائيات تبرز لنا من
المتورط اكثر في مثل هكذا عمليه قتل نتحدث
عنها
يمكن هو يعني يعني يتعلى مستوى العالم كله
في جرائم قتل يعني عنف اسري وبتوصل لجرام
القاتله دي موجوده على مستوى العالم كله
ولكن الحقيقي ان هي مع الاسف على حسب
منظمه الصحه العالميه كانت يعني قالت
المرتبه الثانيه هي منطقه الشرق الاوسط
اللي هي يعني
اتحدث عن مستويات اجتماعيه لانه الدكتوره
من الاستاذه راضيه منذ قليل تقول لي لا
ليست هناك دراسات راضيه ان كان ال- ال-
مثلا اللي مستواه اجتماعي متوسط او فقير
معرف اكثر للتحرك او الغني يعني هل هناك
خصوصيه في ذلك او تعم او تشمل كل الاطراف
هي بالفعل الظروف الاقتصاديه الدكتوره امل
ساعود ساعود لك الدكتوره امل ساعود لكي
تفضلي يا استاذ راضيه
الدراسه التي نشرت في تونس بينه وان العنف
المثلت عن النساء من كل شرائح العمريه
للذكور من كل
الاوساط الاجتماعيه من كل مستويات
الثقافيه ليس هنالك في دون اخرى تتميز
بالعنف نفس الشيء الدراسه التي سنقدمها
يوم 29 من هذا الشهر الخاصه
على العنف المثلث على الايثارات العليا من
الاطارات العليا بمعنى انه همم هاتي
الدراسه تؤكد مره اخرى وان العنف ايضا لا
ثقاف فتاه او لا مستوى علمي له وانما هو
منتشر بين كل الاوساط ومهما تقدمنا في
العلم والمعرفه او في المكان الاجتماعيه
فان همم العقليه السائده بانه بيسع الرجل
مهما كانت همم مكانته حتى وان كان ليس
الزوج او القارئ او احد افراد الاسره حسن
كان رئيسك في العمل
يرى نفسه انهاتي السلطه تسمح له بان يمارس
عنفا على المراه
وهذا هو الخطير جدا لانه لا اعتقد انه
التشريع نحن نحتاج الى مزيد من التشريعات
اعتقد ان نحن محتاجين الى حمايه النساء
اولا وايضا الى تطبيق هذه التشريعات لان
كل دول تقريبا
يجب حمايه المراه كيف
احميتها اولا حتى لا تخاف لانه المشكله
بالنسبه للنساء هو الخوف الخوف من التشكي
الخوف من تداعيات التشكي الخوف من ما بعد
التشكي لابد ان تجد حمايه كبيره هنالك
مؤسسات
اجتماعيه ومجتماعيه ومؤسسات ايضا الدوله
يجب ان يجب ان تحميها
لضيق الوقت فقط دكتوره امل هل هذا متوفر
على الاقل على مستوى المجتمعاتنا العربيه
ان تكون هناك مراكز تستمع للمراه المعنفه
حتى لا تصل لمرحله المراه المقتوله
هي المراكز دي موجوده ولكن هي الفكره في
ان المراه اصلا تصل الى حد الشكوى هي
بتستحمل لان ثقافه المجتمع دائما بتحسها
على التحمل على التسامح التسامح شيء جميل
جدا ولكن ليس مع العنف اللي ممكن يوصل
للجريمه فانا هنا محتاج ان انا اغير الوعي
عند الناس غير المفاهيم واصحح المفاهيم ان
قبول العنف وقبول الخطا التسامح يبقى احنا
محتاجين ان انا التغيير مجتمعي مع فكره
التعديل او تشريعات القانونيه ضد العنف
الاسري مع الاخذ في الاعتبار ان المخدرات
علم الاجتماع ومن تونس راضي رئيسه الاتحاد
الوطني للمراه التونسيه شكرا لكم السلام
عليكم